[Musique]
au général pendant le film ça se passe
forcément plutôt bien puisque du coup on
est tous cas elle me regarde
mais après ça va commencer un peu des
joueurs des fois on l'écouté défend l'
écoute pas je sais pas du tout si j'ai
écouté ce soir tu as intérêt dès
vendredi reconfirme ans les écoles
resteront ouvertes
figurez-vous que pierre mme signalait
que ce soir au voc soir alors que c'est
l'une de nos dernières séances
c'est notre dernier dîner à vrai dire
avant de huy avant de fermer le rideau
des dîners de c'est à vous parce qu'à
partir de demain on arrête de recevoir à
tapis ce qu on passe en mode confinement
y compris à la télévision comme les
restaurants et les bars seront fermés à
partir de ce soir minuit on ferme
également le restaurant de 7 à vous donc
notre dernier des mais c'est avec
l'homme de la dernière séance quand le
partage et son fils avec 1500 euros
quand vous avez 3000 ou 4000 euros de
loyer quand vous avez quatre mille 4000
euros de frais fixes à payer et que vous
ne vous versez même pas salaire juste
m'expliquer comment on fait qu'ils
supporteraient aujourd'hui de ne pas
être payés pendant plus de sept mois
pendant plus de sept mois et c'est une
réalité
est ce que est ce qu'un fonctionnaire
l'accepta est ce qu'un médecin accepte
presque un professeur personnes
accepterait ça et pourtant dans notre
métier ça arrive
il ya des gens aujourd'hui qui ne se
verse plus de salaire depuis sept mois
[Musique]
en lançant la javanaise joël mettre en
haut elle un peu rude pas aussi drôle
que d'habitude surtout quand on en
général ont voyagé
pas mais aujourd'hui on reste confondu
la bulle sur les lunettes que pour la
souvent merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre je n'invite le miz la santé à
me rejoindre pendant ce temps près de 19
mille malades du coronavirus sont
actuellement hospitalisées un niveau
supérieur au 28 mars alors même que le
confinement avaient démarré depuis 11
jours
même constat côté réanimation le bilan
est donc pire aujourd'hui que celui du
16 mars lorsqu emmanuel macron avait
annoncé la mise sous cloche du pays
cette fois au moins on a l'expérience du
premier confinement alors on s'attend
déjà aux ordres de joggeurs et à voir
débarquer des animaux en ville on
prépare également des paniers garnis
spéciaux et on recycle les blagues de
peur d'une pénurie vent papier toilette
50 euros l'unité
pas sérieux s'abstenir quand j'entends
parler de de la fermeture fin de
l'ouverture des choses essentielles
on oublie quand même que ça c'est
essentiel aussi la nourriture la
littérature les librairies ça devrait
être resté ouvert enfin bon c'est plus
important que d'acheter des bateaux
enfin bon si ça peut faire les deux ça
se passe c'est d'ailleurs là bas qu'il a
choisi de se confiner dans un hôtel 4
étoiles dans les alpes allemandes
abandonnant ses 70 millions de sujets en
pleine crise sanitaire
mais rassurez-vous renault il était en
bonne compagnie avec son harem de 20
jeunes femmes alors cet exil doré est
restée en travers de la gorge des
thaïlandais qui ont popularisé hashtag
pourquoi avons nous besoin d'un roi
m
[Applaudissements]
et on me connaît deux passions les
avions et les femmes c'est donc en toute
logique et l'a épousé une hôtesse de
l'air bien en quatrièmes noces et qui
l'a couronné bavaroise on vous la voyez
thaïlandaise vous la voyez ici aplatit
au sol le jour de son mariage
alors pour assouvir sa boulimie sexuelle
et la légaliser la polygamie en
thaïlande mais uniquement pour son
souverain bien entendu alors moi je
dirais c'est plutôt les cadeaux alors il
est toujours à côté c'est un truc de fou
l'autre fois il m'a offert je
m'attendais à un truc de fou il m'avait
dit je vais te faire un cadeau de
malades et tout ça il m'offre un truc
pour faire pipi debout
ah ben c'est un cadeau de malade peut
pas s'asseoir on l'appelle aussi la
reine du shopping et vous allez le voir
ses goûts sont faites au olé olé quand
ils ne portent pas l'uniforme c'est un
fan du cros octobre et des jeans taille
basse à la limite de l'intimité alors
autres extravagances son amant fou voilà
son caniche que vous voyez là qu'il a
décoré maréchal de l'armée de l'air
alors la mort est bien le roi rama 10
est inconsolable et proclame quatre
jours de deuil national
mais moi aussi mais non bonjour yoga
j'aurais pas copine avec top moi je le
mange le pool et moi et nous les femmes
en fait on danse différents quelles sont
les femmes ont à prendre avec les bras
les mains utilise beaucoup les cambrai
les mouvements d'un centre et auront et
les hommes
comment vous fait plaisir mais oui oui
oui au lait il attend je veux pas mourir
d'inanition d'inanition mais je me
tirais gilet avec mes rêves j'aime pas
trop les ips terre je préfère ceux qui
me disent au mont wright elle sans
qu'elle s'en s'agissait peut-être pas du
freestyle mais je crois que ça fera le
job ça fera le job
la beauté vous et des malades de faire
d'être comme ça
esprit es tu là qui se font pas parce
qu'ils croient pas moi j'y crois
beaucoup c'est parce que j'y crois je le
fais pas et voilà donc j'observe et je
me dis voilà qui est en train de jouer à
un truc qui contrôlent pas quand je skie
kabila ben je suis dégouté je suis privé
et d'une aventure alors que je trouve ça
à poste de grecs et peut s'excuser
jusqu'à demain matin se mettre à genoux
mais celle orteil gauche pardonnerai
jamais je ne veux plus rien savoir de
vie c'est fini
là ils ont fait la queue n'attend pas et
on commence avec les pieds ba est
toujours la posture là on regarde aille
pas à aller pas débordé de partout où je
veux embrasser mes parents je ne veux
plus avoir peur des câlins je ne veux
plus porter le masque
je veux par exemple aller voir la
juventus du turin dans un match
directement au stade cela il vous auriez
pu l'écrire renault ou tout simplement
je veux rattraper le temps perdu car la
peur est contagieuse mais l'espoir aussi